I have here with me uh Kevin McMahon and
Monty Brown both uh connected with the
institute for for quite some time in a
number of different capacities uh you
know you both presented under the
auspices of The Institute and uh now
Monty is the the director Kevin is in
charge of the metaphysics colloquium and
some other things as well right right
hand man as you can see yeah that's
basically the main thing yeah
yeah so um we're doing some some uh
interviews and parts so that you can get
a sense of what goes on here at the
Institute because I think a lot of
people outside of academics still have
much idea about you know what academics
actually do so
um why don't we start by each of you
introducing yourselves and saying how
you got involved with the institute in
the first place because I don't actually
know okay because you're actually on the
original committee so once you start off
and then I was yes so Kevin McMahon
teach theology here at Saint ansem since
1984. and when it was that John Fortin
or the John Fortin member of the
community here first had the idea of the
Institute and when would I have been
Monty uh I think
it was there was the idea of the
collection started first from 1990 Kevin
Staley got a summer research Grant to
work on a bibliography to collect the
works of Edison and then I think then we
planned on a conference in 2000 right
and then the Institute actually got
underway in 2001. okay 2001. and to have
the college supporting The Institute
when there had to be an oversight you
might okay the oversight committee and
so I was appointed a member of that
committee
um because of my background medieval
Theology and they like to have a
historian and someone from philosophy
some from English literature uh but I
was made a chair and uh
August position because who else wants
to do it nobody uh you know sense uh and
and then um
one of the program when we were talking
about things The Institute might do of
course we had that that was in some
conference and we were still thinking of
with what regularity we would have that
kind of a conference an invited
conference in Saint ansum so we had the
one in 2000 and then the next one was
2000 we did 2000 to 2004. we tried to do
another in 2006 and didn't have I
remember yeah so we expanded a little
bit The Horizon of what we wanted to do
had it had a conference in 2009 that's
right anniversary of anselves death and
then we just had one in 2014. and the
plan does not have one every three years
so spring is 2007 yeah so at first it
was like every other year that we
discovered that would be
frequent yeah for people to address
things with the senators in the meantime
well that's we had the idea of well
doing other things besides just the
conference and one of those things was
the the metaphysics colloquium so that
emerged from from that that was just one
of the ideas that was thrown out there I
didn't realize that the back story
extended so far that um I mean it was 10
years from originally starting to think
about it to the first conference because
my my enrollment began with that that
first conference right and I think with
a lot of people I think it was beginning
to collecting the books uh I think Jim
O'Rourke had
um very important in organizing this and
the inspiration and the funding for for
The Institute and for the collection so
he was involved earlier on but I think
people got together in committee and
tried to figure out what can we do for
the Centennial year 2000 something on
the inside yeah good so that was the
inspiration for getting the conference
conference going and is to never mind
Father John yeah now I uh Professor
Martin Brown from philosophy Department
I've been involved in the beginning not
uh on the committee but I presented the
first conference and quite early within
the first maybe three or four years of
The Institute we organized a satellite
session in the fall and it was at the
PMR a couple times but mostly it's been
at the American uh statistic committee
on Renaissance conference in Villanova
uh the first couple years it was there
and then it's really been at the
American Catholic philosophical
association meeting yeah it's been the
last 12 years
and I was fairly on Father John asked me
if I sort of organized that so I started
doing that when he was the director
while Dwayne Bruce was the second
director and I still organized that yeah
you know when I actually started
charting it out there's a lot of
different
moving parts to the The Institute
um you know there's the annual not the
annual the tri-annual now conference the
annual metaphysics colloquian satellite
session so there's already three main
Scholars and you will send in some
lecture that's right that's true yeah
every year
every year I mean by The Scholar to
speak on some machines that's relevant
to say on some of the studies to
coincide typically with uh
yeah this year is actually on these days
that's nice yeah and then you guys have
the Saint Anselm Journal which which
ties all these things together yeah yeah
the journal uh I think is is a great
opportunity for Scholars we the uh
invited papers that we
that we collect for the satellite
session in the fall but also for the
metaphysical we publish those they are
invited uh and beyond that
um if people submit uh papers then we
send them out to referees double blind
review and if we include those as well
if they're if the reviewers think it's
appropriate and at least the last
conference uh we had in 2014 has some
submissions which they also sent out to
referees and you published some of those
so if they're forthcoming actually in
the next issue yeah so you can you can
create a resource right so all the
fruits of the laborers Father John
Fortin uh because he was the one who
masterminded the idea of an online
journal and saw really into completion
yeah wow yeah you did a lot of work for
the second Institute
yeah he was a real Workhorse he's a very
good medievalist yes
so there's there's all of that
um what else is is the Institute
involved in or actually we should talk
about the medical school plan because we
haven't gotten to that and that's
happening in a couple days yeah sure
well again that was one of the other
things that came out early on we were
talking about different things Institute
might uh sponsor besides just a
conference on Saint Andrew and so I had
this idea of basically like a faith and
reason program but to begin with
um because uh fetus that razio faith and
reason why John Paul II had come out in
1998 uh this was a couple years later
and there in that letter uh he had
spoken of the importance of a
metaphysics for the Contemporary age
that's true that is uh the importance of
philosophy and theology working together
in order to explicate the faith and to
present the faith yeah uh to present the
faith there's something that you know is
intelligible on some terms
and so I had the idea well one of the
things we might initially do would be to
have this kind of a gathering where
catech philosophers and theologians
could come together and talk about
essentially uh the formation of a
Catholic metaphysics we'll go into that
now you know I have some background
philosophy obviously PhD in theology so
I didn't know where to start so the
first thing we did was we held a
gathering a one-day gathering this I
think was in 2002.
to bring people together to brainstorm
so
um uh we this was again Father John Fort
he was great uh you know as a person who
could organize things he sent out flyers
to all the you know philosophy and
theology departments in the Northeast so
he just blanketed uh this this
invitation to come to sinai's we had at
least 30 you know perhaps more people
who came uh we had several folks from
Boston College Steve Brown was here I
probably Matt lamb uh who at that time
was at BC then went down to Ave Maria
but um he came a number of grad students
showed up and just about the entire
department of philosophy from Saint
Amazon came and um
I'd asked Kevin Stanley a member of the
philosophy Department who had been
teaching a metaphysics course and he
would give a paper basically just on the
state of metaphysics today I mean what
do metaphysicians talk about exactly he
focused on what was interested in him
which was basically the issue of time
but in the event uh because I just want
to get an idea okay what do these folks
think about what are they talking about
and is really kind of you know interface
between what they're talking about and
what might be a relevance to theology uh
and so Kevin gave the paper we broke up
into small group discussions and people
just brainstormed him out of that came
among ideas that there would be an
overnight Affair uh so um that we would
have
um a single topic with a main paper on
that topic and then respondents so that
there would be essentially a two-day
conversation and that's how
it was first pitched it's supposed to be
a workshop so you have academics coming
together and they're going to actually
be kind of in a collaborative way
grappling with some particular problem
in metaphysics that would relate to
philosophy and theology like substance I
mean you can talk about substance and
philosophy and transubstantiation uh in
theology so these things that really
would kind of be a mutual interest
um and it was kind of clever because uh
one year you'd have a theologian be the
main speaker and a theologian and a
philosophical next year would be the
main speaker with the theology exactly
exactly now over the years it became
more difficult than by theologians you
know we're interested in talking about
these things but that was Monty's right
that was always the idea to have that
back and forth it would be that parity
that may not that notion of real
collaboration yeah um and then you know
just it just took off from from there
what has really been most attractive has
been the idea of it being overnight so
you have an ongoing conversation and the
idea of there being you know more
coherence because typically you go to a
conference right and there are a bunch
of different papers given by different
people could be in a lot of different
ideas you listen to a paper and everyone
leaves and a discussion in the
conversation yeah a little pigeonhole
the person yeah people like the idea
that you know you would have a
conversation that would go on everybody
would be in all three papers and write
this conversation with you yeah and then
you know you guys Supply the meals as
well and there's there's sort of a
tradition of uh yeah well but also that
at night there is the sitting around and
chatting in the lounge and catching up
with each other I think there's there's
sort of a community that is developed
out of this you know people look forward
to going to this each year I know I
certainly do
um so that's what we do uh here at Saint
ansum the satellite session is focused
really more on the historical certain
Amazon yeah sometimes papers on his own
work but also some of his predecessors
Augustine Aquinas who are some of his
influences so um that is the more
historically based so and some always
features directly in that conversation
and sometimes all the honey and
sometimes
and I think this year we're doing
Augustine and sound and Aquinas on on
heaven and hell so it's a kind of
interesting question okay and the first
three so first four of the conferences
were mostly on the historical Anthem and
that's true with the last one we thought
well
it's just hard to get that many people
working on that on that historical line
uh material so this year last time we
did was in church and state which is
obviously an idea that's very important
France I think that's our idea in the
future a little bit larger topic that
can feel both historical stuff on Amazon
but also systematic questions and faiths
and Views yeah there were other people
presenting uh
um thinkers other than and some
uh usually in panels that included one
paper on hand so right so it was a very
successful conference I thought
um
do you guys have the the theme yet for
the the next one no we really don't we
have a kicking right now yes we will we
will have that in place uh certainly by
early next year because we want to give
a full year to roll this out in terms of
advertising it it was kind of neat too
um with the conference is that uh of
course in some college is a small
College it's undergraduate college and
we always try to focus on uh fostering
this kind of interest and working apart
undergraduates yeah and so yes you know
you have your uh your main attendees who
are recommendations they're already well
known in the field and you'll have
graduate students in addition but beyond
that we always have an undergraduate
panel yeah and uh you know there'll be
students from Saint ansen but you know
from other schools too in the area
that's always assumption I hope they'll
come and they'll get papers it's a great
experience for them to be an academic
conference and to have uh Professionals
in the audience and respond to them give
them feedback on their papers from the
very beginning we've always had at
undergraduate component too which I
think is unusual and it's very important
you know the the plenary lectures for
the conference are always very well
intended by Saint Anselm undergraduates
right um and you see some of them too in
the panel discussions of the audience
right
so typically I know one year we did have
two plenary speakers we've done that in
about some of the conferences the last
one we just had one plenary speaker
Robert George from president who gave
the ansemble dress and the the
conference uh talk with the same that
year oh it happens okay yeah
so
um let me ask you a couple other
questions
what would this is an open-ended one
what would you say the the purpose and
the contribution of The Institute is to
and some scholarship
for you know people who don't really
know put it in terms for people who
don't actually understand necessarily
what academics are up to
well I think the fact that we invite
people to these two uh sessions the one
in historical Session One the
metaphysical session gives people an
opportunity to work on material with
support and knowing that what they do
will see the light of day and it's kind
of publication yeah that's important and
I think people like that and and and
also we can therefore choose topics that
we think are really important not just
what the journals that happen to be out
other journals might want to accept uh
we can steer some important research on
on topics particularly topics which we
think are very important and close to
Saint Anselm's heart of faith and reason
so you know it's not just philosophy
it's not just theology it's not just
those two it's also history and his work
as a as a bishop and Archbishop
so it's wide ranging and it helps those
things support uh in an active way
ideas and com comments on Amazon
tradition this is also an incredible
support though yes the special
collection well yeah and just maybe a
few words about that uh this special
collection that we have here uh we're
we're trying to get everything on Amazon
here and we're reasonably close to we'll
probably have a better collection than
it than exists anywhere else yeah that
goes back to 1990 when Professor Kevin
Staley philosophy Department got a
summer research Grant to to work on
updating the kind of bibliography and to
look at what papers have been done and
since that time you've been trying to
collect uh uh all the books on ASM and a
bunch of dissertations that you've been
working on yeah uh there's quite a few
well that's one other piece too of the
original plan at least from yeah uh
Father John is that we would have a
scholar on occasion to come to San
ansong and uh Greg happily did that in
the initial time and then we had some
work here that needed to be done on our
collection and he volunteered uh to come
back to Summer to work on that but I
think we'd like to get that if not every
summer at least every other summer and
maybe maybe Target uh ask me a question
I'll be trying to Foster future growth
in the scholarship uh graduate students
I think that's a great idea of abds that
are working on their dissertation yeah
there's so many things in the collection
here that I wouldn't even have known
existed if I didn't have the opportunity
if there's you know you can get things
online but actually being able to hold
books in your hand and then like pour
through them
um and and read in this this isn't quite
Stacks but it's like that that's
invaluable for a scholarship because you
just don't know until you actually go to
it what there is and some of those
dissertations you know the authors a lot
of them are actually
um authors who are religious and they
didn't publish them because they were
particularly interested in you know
furthering their their academic career
and and there's some great stuff in
there you know there's also some things
that aren't anseling related that are
really interesting as well for
medievalists and maybe because we have
other Outreach ideas in mind for The
Institute too not just for Scholars
themselves but you know some of the
things you know we talked about I mean
certainly uh what academics do
should really be thinking about the
stuff formally that is relevant to
anybody yeah I mean thinking about stuff
that anyone would think about maybe
think about a greater length of he or
she had more time to think about that
stuff but you know they don't academics
do so hopefully you know when you're
talking about an Institute like this
that Fosters that kind of study and
reflection on a part of academics or
professionals their own work can
actually be a kind of yeast 11 for uh
reflection of just ordinary people
um and as Monty is saying um The
Institute is looking to expressly not
just kind of like an indirect Way by
fostering the the work of professionals
but then having programs uh itself that
will draw non-professionals but but
people who are still interested in these
sorts of questions I can remember uh
years ago uh Kevin Staley got in any age
Grant to put together a colloquium uh
whose Central text was Zen and the Art
motorcycle repair yeah yeah maintenance
and of course that's all about you know
I guess you could say the sorts of
philosophical type questions that are
non-professional would would ask and uh
I think it was designed for high school
teachers it was and I so I think that's
an idea we have in mind is to reach out
not only to Foster the real The Cutting
Edge of scholarship and face amazing
questions but also spread it around I
mean they love that opportunity Unity to
come together and to talk you know about
this kind of stuff uh you know in an
environment that was a horrible
environment but it wasn't one that was
you know Associated that you know it was
just changed
exactly and we're hoping that the
Institute can do more things along those
lines for more General audience that
sounds wonderful and hope hope that uh
what it is the professionals do uh under
the Aegis of his two can can actually
augment that so you do have that
reciprocity I think a lot of people
don't really when they think about Ansel
and they think about this guy who you
know wrote these books and they may have
a few things in mind about you know
having to deal with church stay
controversy but they forget he was a
essentially a professional once he
became prior in the monastery he was in
a teaching role and they had to teach
these guys right from the ground up and
do some actually because his Abbott was
Ill he had to do a lot of the
administrative work and then they made
poor guy they made him Abbott and then
he had even more and then kicking and
screaming they made him Archbishop and
then it was worked you know from South
to sun down he was a second Archbishop
of Canada after Joanne Frank was the
first so William brought landfrank over
and then yeah his son but I guess so
unfortunately it seems to have
established a few precedents yeah but I
think so handsome is a great figure uh
for a scholarship because he's a
brilliant thinker so yeah that's
philosopher Anthony about you but he's
also a very great teacher uh an able
administrator he dealt with Kings and
popes and stuff and trying to deal with
that so man of many talents and his
meditations and prayers yeah beautiful
experience yeah
that was actually the question I was
going to ask uh sort of to bring things
to a close why is it important to study
it so
well I mean I think
such a pivotal figure and he's very you
know if you asked him you know
who's your influence well it's Augustine
I'm just yeah I never I don't say
anything that Gustin didn't say of
course he does say a few things I got
something to say but he's really
building on that so the whole the whole
tradition of faith in the museum is so
important and then it it goes from him
obviously to Thomas Aquinas and Newman
and John Paul and you know Church
intellectual tradition so he's very
pivotal that way
uh and to me I just gave a paper it's in
Vincent's Abby which is the mother house
in Saint Anselm on uh the faith and
reason question and and some is he's
just so convinced in the goodness of
reason there's no place we say no more
for a reason reason no if you have the
reason to express it on the other hand
without the faith we probably lose our
Focus
um in terms of humility and love for the
truth for its own sake yeah that's
dangerous so we really need both of them
and both Full Throttle for him there's
no there's no uh Magic dividing line
where where Faith can't go beyond that
and reason can't go the other way so
it's the whole human being thinking
about
everything was important
what do you think Kevin I think that's
true I think that uh you know
um if you're just talking about the
nature of theology theology is a
questioning discipline it's all about
asking questions now of course
there's a sense in which the answers
were there yeah the faith but
uh theology is always asking questions
about the faith I mean you're making
this claim how does that make sense or
how do you fit this claim in with this
claim you know I try and gone with the
Incarnation or the Incarnation with the
resurrection of the body assuming that
it all forms a single coherent whole
that's the answer but the The
Devout person the curious person can't
help but ask questions about that and
you know you can ask questions that get
you into all kinds of trouble but the
importance is Monty was saying about and
some first of all confidence in reason
and actually being able to ask the right
questions and arrive at uh workable uh
answers to those questions put to the
faith and also the willingness to take a
risk if you have that kind of confidence
and reason you got to be willing to put
out those questions even if in fact they
might go off in bad directions
say Okay that was a bad question or it
might in fact lead to a complete
misunderstanding the answer is not to
stop asking the questions the answer is
okay then let's ask different questions
that can show how it is at that
particular line is a mistaken line and
so if you go back to John Paul and
fidesa razio the idea of a metaphysics
that's about everything that is Faith
and reason too so metaphysics isn't just
a philosophical discipline
and the greatest of the metaphysicians
played on Aristotle are open-ended I
mean yeah they don't close down Dan and
so their methods are very suitable and
because Ann Solomon and maybe Thomas
More for Aristotle make use of those
methods in trying to understand the
faith it's a very rich
meeting of the two Traditions yeah well
so to come back to the institute for a
close it seems like you know it's it's
going along very well it's very robust
you guys have a lot of interesting
projects going on and so uh I'm you know
myself I'm very happy to see that coming
in from the outside benefiting from
uh structure that you guys can create
right yeah and I think I think it is
healthy and we're trying to to manage
all these different pieces of it uh not
to lose
uh the metaphysis scope it may morph a
little bit into something a bit more
General is this year it's on on what
Catholicism are in Beauty right which is
related certainly
um but we want to also keep the idea of
that workshop on some of those really
tough questions it's a fairly small
group how did that happen and uh the
other side of things maybe things for
the diocese maybe things for the high
school teachers that open up what we're
doing to other people without the same
kind of training yeah professional
training
that makes sense
so I'm here with with Jim O'Rourke
somebody who's been very uh Central to
the beginnings and the ongoing
operations of the institute for Saint
Anselm studies very happy to have him
here because I can get a lot of the back
story from here
um thanks yeah so um I mean one thing we
ought to start off by talking about it's
the overall collection the in the Geisel
Library so how did that come about
well uh it began in
19.
90 approximately
we were talking about the
uh
the development of the college
I believe this was spurred on by
a celebration
our Sesame Millennial celebration
of
lead us the first the birth of the death
of Saint Ansel
process handsome yeah in any case
we were thinking about the college and
it occurred to me that
uh from
that we ought to specialize so to speak
in the thought of saint anselor
that we are Saint Ansel College we're
the only college named after Saint
Anselm
in the United States
there are a few in the world this
obviously went in Rome and I think
there's another in Europe
and uh
it occurred to me that we ought to have
the resources
to for a complete
uh thorough study of science
and at the time our library
I believe only had two special
collections one of them was a collection
New England folks I don't know what the
other one was
right now
but the idea occurred to me that we
could develop a collection of works by
and on Saint Ansel
that would be
relatively complete
and for several reasons
our library is not a huge research
Library yeah and so we have limited we
have limited space and limited resources
San ansome
himself didn't write not write a lot of
works you could
get all of his Works in a in a single
value maybe a couple inches thick
and the writings on San anso would be of
an extent such that we could reasonably
expect to acquire them for the uh for
the college collection
uh we could not have done the same thing
say uh Thomas
St Thomas Aquinas should have a
collection a complete collection
of verse bye and on St Thomas Aquinas
would be out of the reach of our library
yeah
so uh first of all it was appropriate to
have such a collection because of the
name of the college and secondly it was
Within Reach
um
because of the scope of works on San
Anselm
and thirdly
what Saint Anselm wrote thought about
and wrote about
were related in the very intimate way
to what the college
firm is his goals if you wish as the way
of implementing his mission
San ansem famously discusses the great
existential questions of human life the
nature of human freedom God evil sin and
the devil and so forth okay and those
key questions at that time at least form
the center of our Core Curriculum in
philosophy and theology
uh and so it was appropriated again in a
different way
for us to focus on Saint Anson
and finally there was a fourth reason we
did this we had the personnel
we had several people who were involved
in
immediate philosophy and theology
Kevin Stanley for example Monty Brown
and uh we had a father and son at the
time oh
uh was he involved in the not really
okay
but but and of course we have the
presence of the monastic Community right
so obviously the Benedictine tradition
Kevin Staley uh started us off
by uh developing a bibliography with a
summer research Grant in bibliography
of writings on Saint Ansel mostly
writings in Philosophy by philosophers
and theologians okay and that formed the
basis
for the collection so then and then
later we acquired those words first and
then we later uh adopted the
bibliography by Kingsland Kinsler
which which now I think just about
completed firing okay
um but the the original impetus
was to develop a collection in the
library okay yeah it was not the form of
The Institute that's what I was
wondering The Institute uh area was
founded almost 10 years after
The Collection collection we had the
idea of the collection okay
distinctly remember
the excitement that we had
I was sitting in my office thinking
about the college and its resources
I had the idea of developing a
collection of books on San Anselm and I
thought it was a great idea so I walked
over to Kevin Staley's office and he was
there and Father John Horton was there
and I said what do you think of this and
within uh a week
we had a kind of plan for the collection
of first works by Saint ansar sources of
Saint Ansel of works on philosophy
theology were the era of Saint Anne's
culture culture and so forth in in a way
uh constructing the collection
as as a series of concentric circles
okay around the works of Saint Anselm
okay
but then it was uh
I think closer to the year 2000
uh that we we established the Institute
Father John fort News instrumental in
that
he
wanted to do with me put together a
committee which I chaired yeah and uh I
argued it before the curriculum
committee he took it to the
sort of advocacy work that's pronounce
the governing board at that point it was
already I think a
believe we're the Board of Trustees okay
so I made the presentation to The
Landmark trustees and they approved it
and uh
started holding conferences
and so far we've had quite a few
yeah five so far right so five we know
better than I do yeah I didn't miss one
okay you know I my my beginning and then
if we just continue just to get the big
the big picture Kevin McMahon Professor
Kevin McMahon was the
who's the author of The metaphysics
colloquian that was his idea down the
metaphysical opium
so now we have three regular events the
conference and that we have usually a
panel at the American Catholic
philosophical association meeting
uh and then thirdly we have the
metaphysical opium that we're engaged in
right now you know
and then we added to that the ad so I'm
not sure once a year there's a lecture
on some aspect of Saint Anselm uh that
also
preceded the Anson Institute oh that
actually I didn't know that yeah I think
it was the second thing that occurred
after the collection after we started
working but it was tied in with the
project of the collection
oh it was just it seems something that
supported it just fit okay
because in those days we were
establishing
uh funds for lecture series
okay you may remember all I've told us
yeah okay we established a whole lot of
Tourism lecture fund to have one one
lecture a year in honorable policy
um
there I think were other lecture funds
established in those years of the
college
but we thought it would be appropriate
to have a lecture on Saint Anselm once a
year yeah so we set up a fund and got
funding for it and so forth
and then so those two events
came first and then the Anselm Institute
was established which then sponsored the
the second conference I believe the
first conference was run
for The Institute was improved oh the
first conference we had yes interesting
it was significantly the first the first
conference was organized by the
librarian and Father John Horton and
myself and others have you know it was
kind of uh
as a seat of the pants
really and I was there for that it was
very well run and
yeah to be sure about this but I'd have
to look at my records that's uh you know
what 30 20 years ago
15 1992 202 it's 20 20s the 2013 years
ago so this whole thing started at least
23 years ago yeah
for a long time yeah
it's a fascinating story you know the
more that I I dig the more threads I'm
finding because you know I'm I'm sort of
what you could call it um
so I get to see the the the facade I
don't see the the right guts of the
operation but it's really interesting to
find out how much was involved and how
far back the plans went
I do have to say too that the collection
is really extraordinary it's a
very helpful resource for anybody who
wants to do serious study on anselves
have all these things at one place and
to be able to you know instead of just
looking at them on a screen to hold them
in your hands
do work with it it's invaluable I know I
couldn't do some of the work that I've
done without actually so oh thanks going
along
we're right there with you and then we
thought
the collection we should contain at
least one
thing
we looked for an actual look for a
manuscript oh the courteous and uh and
we could not find an appropriate
manuscript
of the work by San Antonio I mean
they're very rare
but we did finally locate a first
edition yeah of the cordaeus homo
which was published in the 15th century
published in um
1474.
uh
and it's
I believe accordius homework is the
first book printed
first book by Sam Hunts on printed
the I believe there's a collection of
writings of San Anselm that were printed
previously prior to the career days homo
okay but corday's home was the first
separate world separate single work uh
that was printed after the discovery of
the printing press and we we found that
we purchased that
it's now in the yeah it's a beautiful
Ohio Institute libraries and Institute
library yeah that's kind of neat I see
it every day as a handle something is
you know 500 years old I haven't taken
it out
don't come in with the camera
but that wasn't acquired until what
about five years ago I think
um okay about five years ago so I don't
know
okay yeah is there anything else that
you'd like to say about the Institute
not really not uh
now it's under the able direction of
mounting around
and one of the things The Institute
hopes to do
is to expand
it's it's clientele so to speak yeah
Beyond philosophers and theologians
especially philosophers interested in
the ontological argument and theologians
interested in the courtesy
yeah because anthem's work uh does have
ramifications in other areas and in
education
in particularly the relationship between
church and state
and theology in general in spirituality
yeah and we're hoping that The Institute
will attract
people who are interested in looking at
these more more General living which
areas
so that it doesn't uh
so they will encourage work in areas
that Saint Anselm was interested in but
not necessarily by by working with
handsome texts all the time yeah well
you know according to Adler he was a
great spiritual director you know relate
to just about anybody who came across
and people saw him out for his uh his
counseling so that sounds entirely
appropriate so good well thank you very
much yeah thank you
so I'm very happy to have here uh Father
John Fortin who was the first director
of The Institute for Saint Anselm
studies a very instrumental in many ways
behind the scenes even down to the
present right I think you can safely say
that still
not so much but yeah yeah
um and you know very important in the
the origins of the Institute as well so
I figure I could get a lot of backstory
from you and then hear about you know
the early years and and uh all the
different things that were were going on
so um
do you want to start with with um you
know the sort of the back story I know
that Kevin Staley did that bibliography
and Jim O'Rourke was involved early on
well the the uh this all started uh long
before the Institute was even conceived
of with with the Saint Anselm studies
collection which was a started with a
gift from the O'Rourke family financial
gift to start collecting books about
Saint Anselm uh books and articles and
whatever we could find uh collections of
his printed works
even thought at some point we stopped
looking for manuscripts if we could ever
afford it uh so I I can't remember
exactly when that started I believe that
was in the 80s sometime in the 80s when
that project started Jim was involved I
was asked to be involved Kevin Staley
was involved by the drug Berthold when
he was on the theology faculty was
involved and I think father placidus
Riley okay former president of college
were also involved in that project
um Kevin got a summer research Grant I
believe which enables him to pull a
pretty substantial bibliography together
so that was all going on it was part of
the library's collection
what happened uh with the Institute was
uh in 1999
uh there were a group of Faculty having
lunch in the coffee shop
and has happened sometimes at faculty
tables there was a bit of concern about
what the college was going to do for the
millennial celebration yeah
and it was suggested by someone at the
table and I don't remember who
it wasn't me although I was there uh why
don't we do a conference on Saint Anselm
we've never done anything like that we
did a conference on Saint Benedict for
the college's 100th anniversary in 1889.
in 1999 so 19 1889 1999 it was a big
conference on on
Saint Benedict
which might have included synonym
actually
so a group of us volunteered to get
together and get the idea going and I
missed the first meeting so I was made
chairman that's what I usually those
things happen
um so we arranged this conference and uh
we got gr Evans from England to come
over to be the uh give the keynote
address we had I can't remember exactly
now but probably 35 or 40 papers
we had uh one session for undergraduate
students to give papers
um it was a it was a pretty good
pretty good weekend
um a lot of good the reception was here
in the library as I remember uh not for
that first one was that the song Oh yes
no we did we did Friday evening after
the keynote address we came the
uh headlight Marion was on the committee
yeah so he agreed to close the library
it was a Friday evening they didn't get
a lot of business anyway being an
undergraduate college so close that we
had the reception reception here
we had other meals I think down in the
dining hall and we had most of the uh
sessions in the student center now this
wasn't here yet at that point right this
room was here but it was the access to
the attic okay and it was a general
storage room they just threw stuff in
here yeah it was nothing there was no
there was no window that was just a full
door there was no one to win the door or
anything like that was it the second
conference or the third conference then
when they took people on a tour of the
well the um
what happened was
at the end of that conference there were
a lot of people that approached me
who asked if this was going to happen
again
because they enjoyed so I kind of saw
yeah it would be kind of a shame to lose
this
so I wrote up a proposal to start an
Institute for Saint in some studies this
is the only Saint Anselm College in the
Western Hemisphere we had the same in
some studies collection already started
and it seemed like a natural an actual
setting so I put a proposal together
uh which I then
presented to the dean
and I can't remember the exact process
but it wound up with the governing board
of the college
I happen to be a member of the governing
board at the time so I didn't I recuse
myself from the vote but I I was
certainly pushed that we had just
started uh the The Institute of Politics
the New Hampshire Institute of Politics
the same that same time and
um so there were certain conditions that
were set and but it got approved so um
we started and we set up a committee
here on campus to kind of be an advisory
committee to the director I had someone
else in mind to be the director and was
astounded when the person said no who
who wasn't well I don't want to say oh
okay and then so I by default I wound up
being the director so
um in working with the committee and
then with the librarian he said well
I've got a room it's not being used we
could always fix it up oh so working
with our physical plant people did all
these bookshelves yeah
um this is designed on some room down
and I believe at Boston College which is
where our head librarian was working in
his Doctorate
um which didn't bother me I didn't care
about that part
um couple of us went out for industry
shopping and founders of these uh is
that true no we found them okay yeah we
but we didn't find them in the same
place we found the chairs in one place
in the table someplace else yeah uh we
had a computer
kind of a student computer set up in
here
um so we got we got a sign of the door I
got a couple of pieces of art
um and uh put in a new door with Windows
and the idea was that although it
wouldn't be uh open during the day there
would be times when it would be
accessible so for example I've had class
in here oh really I ran a class now at a
small seminar I had about six students
so we met in here yeah and that was nice
because people could see that the room
was being used
so that was in uh
2001 that the Institute was approved and
this started up and then so the next
conference I think was in 2002
that that's right and that's when this
was ready so part of the part of what we
did at that point was to dedicate
dedicate this place or at least open it
up and let people yeah let people see it
um
uh there's another one in 2004 right yep
we did another one 2004
um and then
um I think we were planting another one
we decided to wait put it off for a
while and we didn't we didn't want to
push it too much uh in the meantime we
had a number of other projects going uh
from the first conference we edited
papers from that and published that uh
we started an online Journal that's
right and on some studies uh again the
head librarian the tech person from the
library and I went up to Dartmouth to
talk to the people they had an online
Journal uh gave us all kinds of advice
and we came back and basically designed
them because there weren't that many
online journals that was that was fairly
new yeah and here's a lot of the online
journals that were available they they
very much looked just like web pages but
the Saint Anselm journal from the start
has had a really distinctive aesthetic
to it yeah we also set up
I don't I can't remember what we call it
it's a
a council of some sort of people not
here but who had some fairly significant
names in the world of philosophy and
Theology and so on
um and I don't know that that's been
changed much I mean Ralph mcenany was
originally one of the people that he has
since passed away I don't know if
they've replaced every place that or
done anything with that but that was
another thing we did we did um
uh I was available to give Retreats
based on the teachings of Saint Anselm
and I did a couple of those I offered to
the Alumni Association to make myself
available to give talks to alumni groups
of audience home uh we did a a booklet
for Linda I remember that yeah uh and
that sold out and we did it and um with
new drawings from father Ian one of the
monks did all the drawings for that so
we've had a second edition of that come
out but a new improved yeah
um
um and there were
um we uh
sponsored uh sessions at the American
Catholic philosophical Association
um annual conference
um I was hoping at some point to get to
some other conferences
um
The Majestic material and Renaissance
conference in Lenovo was one that kind
of changed a bit so we never got
involved in that I was hoping to get
something going with leads over in Leeds
as an annual medieval conference and
yeah try to do something there
um sometimes there's things with the
Kalamazoo conference aren't they uh or
we uh that was one of the places we were
going to look at eventually to go to go
to I'm you know we went up to that I'm
not a big fan of the Kalamazoo
conference because there's just too many
people yeah it's just it's just too big
but maybe at some point the The
Institute will move in that direction
I'm trying to think of some of the I I
remember distinctly that I listed 14
things that the Institute could be doing
but uh wow you know that was 14 years
ago 15 years ago when I put that put
that all together well I think it took
having somebody and I'm going to sort of
you know praise you here it's not
flattery uh but you're you're a very
Dynamic uh administrator you get things
done you have you you're you have a
great imagination for what could could
be the case and I think if if the
Institute didn't have somebody like you
at the start it wouldn't have it
wouldn't have grown like that well we
did we did all right we had
um we got some trustees interested who
are very generous
um one of the other programs was um
no set up a program for a graduate if a
graduate student was working on ansoft
to do a summer internship here uh I
don't know that that ever got nothing
around or hasn't gotten off the ground
yet is what I should say yeah all those
things are still possibilities well you
know the summer research residency that
that I did this Summer that was pending
now and then I did one in 2009 I think
that was part of it but now the plan is
for it to be 80d yeah grad students yes
um yeah so I think that's going forward
yeah so there's there were a lot of
things so I I basically started with the
program in 2001 and then in 2007 I
finally got a sabbatical
as a visiting scholar
um so um
it was decided that and and also one of
the things that was going on at that
time is that the the director of The
Institute reported to the Executive Vice
President
which meant that the institute's
activities got into the vice president's
report to the trustees okay so they were
always aware of at least that the the
meetings yeah they had a report on what
was going on here
um so the The Institute was handed over
to another person when I went off on
sabbatical
um and there was some change in the
administration so
it reported to the dean of the college
from that point on and uh
I don't think it quite got the publicity
that it had been getting yeah and
previously and then so uh Dwayne Bruce
was the second director he was the
associate dean of the college he did it
for a number of years he retired and now
Monty Brown who was uh in the philosophy
Department
is running it and
uh
Duane had at least one conference
yeah I think that's that's right yeah
and then there was another one
a couple years ago and I I presented at
that then there was another one a couple
of years ago
but um
since uh 2013 I've not been on the
faculty I've uh that's right I've taken
a position uh I'm on loan to the diocese
for three years you got kind of kicked
upstairs in certain ways maybe uh so I'm
on loan for the diocese apparently it
was being an able administrator well
yeah so I haven't been uh that much
involved like I just
I got back from something and came in
for the last two minutes of the last
Talk of the of the last conference the
other thing that we that has been going
on too fairly regularly
um that was Kevin McMahon's idea was the
metaphysics fallopian yeah based on the
Holy Father uh John Paul II's idea about
philosophers and theologians getting
together to talk about Salient issues
so we started that that's a summer uh
that's a wonderful program I think it's
it's a simple overnight
um it's free
for the participants we provide room and
board
it started out with getting a main
speaker
with two responders and then basically
having it as a colloquium so we wanted
to keep it fairly small and normally we
didn't
we wouldn't get more than 15 20 people
which was just in what we wanted so we
would advertise it
to philosophy and theology Departments
of Catholic colleges in New England and
we had a regular crowd that used to come
and then we had every once in a while
somebody knew would come
to the program so that that was done and
has been going on every summer I think
yeah for a number of years now
and the topics change and vary in uh you
know a program like that takes on a life
of its own so the initial idea might
change the idea was to have
a theologian give a presentation of a
philosopher Theologian response and the
next one would be a philosophy of the
main
benef
but that that has changed which is great
uh but this was this was uh Kevin
McMahon
said why don't we think about doing
something like that and then it was it
was not hard to arrange
um and you know the cost was not
Costco is not that great the college is
very very generous uh in that regard to
me so
um so that's another program that that's
been going on so that leads to something
I was I was hoping to get this is this
is uh interviews for
a lot of people who aren't in an
academic situation so they can get an
understanding of what goes on yeah to
put together an academic conference
that's a big production especially the
first time yeah that it happens and that
first Saint Anselm conference was really
extraordinary yeah somebody who went to
it yeah so can you tell people a little
bit about what goes into you know you
know not not in great detail but so just
give an idea of the magnitude of
planning that has to go well again for
that first one uh that was pre-institute
but there's a group of people we had all
been to professional conferences so we
sat down we we just We Came Upon a theme
um
um I think it was CNN song his his life
and influence his influences and yeah uh
something yeah but but we came up came
across the team so then we uh advertised
um put word out uh advertised as widely
as we could today that would be all
internet for the most part and you today
we've got a mailing list too back then
it was a bulletin board yeah yeah yeah
so we set out notices all over the place
I think we sent to we got the mailing
list from when they had the the prayers
conference
um
for the Centennial
we still have the mailing list for
colleges so we we the library loaned me
one of the administrative assistants
kind of as a halftime went through that
and
um see whatever we could update but
addressed it to the chairs of philosophy
and chairs of Theology and chairs of
history departments yeah to all the
Catholic colleges in the country and a
few other places yeah I'm fortunate
actually that you guys sent one to the
Southern Illinois University yes
otherwise I'd have never heard of it
yeah nobody was doing it so it was that
was paper
paper thing we set out and then we we
talked about who we might get or speaker
and I said Gee you know wouldn't it be
great to get Jill Evans uh or uh you
know somebody of that caliber and I said
Gee I don't know so I said I asked one
of the other members of the committee
would you write the letter on behalf of
the group that he would and she
responded she'd be delighted to come so
I took it from there with the
administrative assistant made all the
arrangements uh she was delightful she
was wonderful to have and we got all
these people it's the first time I met
Kate Rogers uh first time I met you yeah
uh met a number of people who've been
very
um very close to the school and have
been regularly participating in our
programs not only in the conferences
here or the colloqui here uh but and
giving papers at the acpa or some of
those other things
um
so we
um
so we did that and then I just I mean
I'm a list guy and so I just sat down
and said if I'm going to bring all these
people here
where would they need to go and how
would I get them there that's right it
was that
um that hotel where I guess the um there
was a big local history with that that
was where the a lot of the reporters for
the Saint Anselm Institute or not
politics well they that wasn't around
yet so this was anybody that would come
up with the primaries I was still
hosting primary debates up here before
that the Institute of politics and the
institute for Saint Anselm studies
started the same year that's right so
that's that's a year after the first
conference so this is the hotel where
the the reporter was downtown I think it
was at the Holiday Inn Downtown it was
the big
is it what is the biggest hotel in town
at the time I think that was later it
was something called the Wayfarer or oh
the Wayfair in Bedford that's right yeah
with the wayfaring Bedford which is now
not there I heard it's yeah it's gone
it's gone uh and so then I arranged that
I said well how am I going to get it
back and forth so we arranged to
uh rent a couple Vans and then I get one
of the honor societies on campus to
agree to be the drivers
uh the red key Society yeah I'm a member
my brother was a member
um we got money from the college to uh
kind of underwrite this I got money from
another fund to pay for the keynote
address from Jillian Evans and then of
course we charged what I thought a
modest conference fee uh so we're able
to to cover the cost and balance it
um I'd arranged for meals which was not
that difficult to do
um I arranged for the where the meetings
would take place uh that must involve a
bit more headaches though yeah well not
really I mean I just called I mean you
know I've been here since 1967. uh this
is now 19. that's it now 1999. people
know me people know who I am so I can
and I can pick up the phone and call
physical plan and talk to the director
of physical planet and say uh what about
this then I can call whoever's in charge
of the Cushing Center which is the
Dean's office and say this weekend
what does it look like nothing scheduled
all right put me down yeah
um for what I said the entire main floor
I need the entire main floor that's
right it was over a lot of it was in the
student side it was most of it was in
the student center the keynote address
was in the science building yeah in the
amphitheater uh and again that was a
phone call to another office no nothing
scheduled for that evening all right I
need it from this time to this time a
librarian was on the committee so we had
already talked about the reception here
so it it
um it worked out it was
see I don't
doing something like that to me is not
difficult it's just a matter of thinking
it through what do I need and when do I
need it yeah and who do I need to
contact to get it and uh if I've got a
budget how much is it going to cost and
things like that you just kind of fell
together I mean I am the great committee
and uh
but uh you know it was fun uh Jim
O'Rourke and I went down to Boston to
pick up Jillian Evans we had a great
talk that's what she told us she
insisted on being called Jillian
um she didn't like or Jill uh she didn't
care for doctor or professor of any of
that stuff
um
and it was and we had that was basically
you know she was here we had people from
Canada
so I could we could officially call it
an International Conference true at that
point I think she was kind of cool
um so I it I think it went it went as
well as
one could expect for a first time yeah
all right and then the outcome is this I
mean part of it is this yeah there's so
many interlocking uh parts to this now
you know
um I can say too as as you know I was in
graduate school at the time and I was
really fortunate to have come across the
advertisement that you sent out because
um it wasn't the the sort of conference
that you put together was not the sort
of thing that I would have gotten
introduced to in the places that I was
going and it was so important for my
formation as a scholar you know
um
these seemingly fortuitous you know
things coming together but if you hadn't
put in all all of you hadn't put in all
that work and preparation that wouldn't
have been available and I think there's
going to be a lot of people over time
who have stories like that including
some who are not even in graduate school
yet you know
well it's our hope I mean I the hope of
this was that it would it was never the
idea that this would become you know
this big
big place because and some Scholars are
a small group of very dedicated people
so the idea was to try to bring them
together yeah and provide them with a
forum that they wouldn't have at a major
conference
you know or you might give a have a
paper to give on hands on but you could
be with people from
different disciplines who are simply
covering that same time period or
something Loosely related to that topic
and so on so the idea was really to make
a place where and a place for
scholarship and research so hence the
Saint Anselm studies collection yeah
this is really moved on so what we do
now because it is uh I believe it's the
largest endowed collection in the
library whenever we buy something we buy
two
so one goes in here which is
non-circulating and one goes into the
circulation oh that's great so all of
this is available we are now ranking out
into anything that comes out on Anson in
any language
really we've been looking for one of the
other things I got I started I don't
know if they've kept up with this but I
got a work study student
whose job for me was to do online
research
to find anything on Anson
and make sure we got a copy of it so we
have a huge collection yeah of Articles
yeah that are separately they're printed
they're filed separately and they're
cataloged in the library collection
center yeah uh which makes it a lot
easier for research we also uh did the
website
uh so we not only did the journal online
Journal but we also did a website where
you can access the journal and also get
into the collection and and see what's
uh see what's available the other thing
about the website was to put on uh links
to
other sites dealing within some that
would and so my first work study student
whose wedding I attended a couple years
ago and they now have a little girl and
he was a criminal justice major of all
things uh but he worked for me he
transferred in at the middle of his
freshman year and he worked with me for
three and a half years wow um
uh and uh he would he would check and I
every six months check the links
if they're
gone get rid of it you know and he was
very good with computers he was very
savvy so yeah we kept everything up up
to date
um
and then after uh then I got another
work study student after that uh who did
very very much the same thing uh was
mostly that online research make sure we
have whatever we have went through that
bibliography that came out um
a few years ago
maybe 10 or 15 years ago now
make sure we have everything that's
bought a copy Market if you don't have
it if you have it uh it's been ordered
you know so that we keep up with
everything so that was that was uh
that's what this has grown so they put a
lot of books in here just to fill it so
we have some of the rare books and yeah
because there's not all of these things
are about inso uh and then the heroics
very generously bought us a first print
edition of the core days homo yeah over
at South Beach or Christie's over
Atlantic which is very nice and very
rare but adds adds really a nice a nice
quality to what's going on here so I you
know I'm pleased that this is one of the
things I look back on we dedicated The
Collection this year to the Aurora
Family uh and it was it was a nice
ceremony it was uh brought back a lot of
good memories uh
of the work that was done the people
that were involved
is there anything else that you'd like
to talk about or no I mean I was happy
to get it started but I've moved on and
other people have done other things now
you've really left a like I may come
back wow that's I don't want my name and
I I told a couple people who had a few
dollars in their pocket that for a
million dollars we'd name it it would be
the such and such Institute for St Anson
studies unfortunately that hasn't come
across yet but this you know one hopes
yeah but I always hope
you gotta get people really into Saint
anselves well it's all got money it's
all relationships it's all relationships
yeah this person the one person I kind
of had in line it didn't have a clue who
when someone was really graduate of the
college but uh science major care but
good relationships and that's yeah
that's mostly what that's all about so
Someday I'm sure it'll come about Monty
is good about that I think I think
you're right yeah so he'll he'll find
something lion was I was on the Board of
Trustees yeah so I had I had access to
to some of the things
all right well thanks very much thank
you Greg enjoyed it yeah thank you
so what would you like to know all right
so I'm here with with Kevin Staley uh
somebody who's important within The
Narrative of the saint Ansel The
Institute for Saint Anselm studies and
the The Collection the guy's a library
um
some of the people who are talking about
it mentioned this bibliography that you
started working on in 1990 well I think
it was like the summer of 1990 okay um
if I'm correct but it was around that
time yeah so we had the idea of an
Institute uh Kimura uh talking about it
one day in his office with Father John
and uh Cena's has summer grants
so I applied for a summer grant that
would
helped me or allow me to give me the
time to compile the most complete
bibliography I could in uh in the period
of you know a couple months over the
summer
and so I did some research and I found
that at that time there was a Canadian
software company
that um
had developed a bibliographical database
that could fetch
uh data from the web and bring it back
in in some form or another
um there wasn't too much of the web at
that time though is there and then you
know but there were um
there were electronic databases yeah I
think line a philologique was uh had a
database yeah I forget the technical
details but in any in any event that
that allowed me to cast
are relatively wide net
and I think I came up with about 1200
references okay of
you know articles books dissertations
yeah
so why why and some in the first place
is it well it's Saint Anselm College so
um we all a lot of people in the um
Department are familiar with and do some
work on it so
including yourself yes yeah yeah most of
my work on ansem I've done in
conjunction with the Institute
published a number of times in its
Journal
I'm presented a number of times as well
at the conferences
yeah and as a part of that I've debated
Katherine Rogers
presented something on Eileen Sweeney's
new book the desire for the word yeah
so yeah I've uh put a lot of scholarly
activity into the Institute as well but
I don't have an executive function on
Amazon you know sort of the seat the
ground the seed yeah a lot of the people
talked about that bibliography activity
is as being the spur to Gathering all
those those articles yeah that was the
purpose okay have a complete get
everything and anything that was
published on hand so with and and and
the circumference of materials that are
relevant I know for myself like last
time that I I did a research residency
here
having all those articles in one place
is really invaluable because I uh you
know there's something about being able
to like hold them in your hands and pour
it through them yeah you know as opposed
to just reading them on a screen
um and I don't think anybody out there
has access
so all of those articles in one place
electronically
you know so if you instead if you come
here you can actually
you can actually see them
yeah I think that would be a nice step
though to make the like the collection
electronic yeah and certainly wide in
the scope because
I mean on the one hand you do want
people to come here you know correct
but on the other hand you could be
reaching a much wider
some audience
um it would just find me it would be
very very should be
um yeah but I don't know what the
copyright issues would be I imagine they
would be multiple yes and complicated
yeah and the collection of texts or
books that we had it's just really
extensive as well yeah
and the dissertations
um I was surprised to see just how many
they have in the you know many of them
have never been published as books or
even cannibalized to make articles so
being able to find those is really
helpful
so you do a lot of work on neoplatonism
yeah I do I do a lot of work in
metaphysics okay so neoplatanism yeah
would be a part of that mix
so you know for people who are just they
don't know that much about Anselm and
are interested in what the Institute
does
Anthem you know he doesn't get an awful
lot of credit as a major metaphysician
but would you say that he is one there
well that's difficult to say it's uh he
does not have uh an explicitly held
metaphysical physician
uh rather I would say that his
metaphysics is implicit yeah you have to
call it out of this text yeah yeah
and uh but you know if I were to and the
metaphysics that you find in the
monologue
uh may not be the same one you find in
the pros of opioid yeah and the
monologue God ends up being the highest
in nature and the use of the superlative
is uh it's uh yeah yeah this or the Suma
that's because it the Suma yes and so
and so you could be the highest in a
series and still be a part of the series
whereas that then which nothing greater
could be conceived
must be off the series yeah and some
people talk about that as a supreme
concept as opposed to the uh superlative
or the summon Natura versus the Supreme
ends yeah anselman actually criticizes
them you know
they don't probably know this Danilo for
mixing the two of them up that's right
that's right
um
and I think he does it because obviously
the logic of the argument requires that
I can't just I can't limit this this
that day which nothing greater could
even see and of course the end of the
series is just a limit
do you think that a lot of the
discussions that reframe the ontological
argument in terms of a perfect being and
uh
falling into treating God as as you know
just the Supreme Being rather than being
you know the the being the god beyond
all these this this other series of
beings in the prosologia do I think the
what though the discussions that try to
reframe it in terms of gossiping
perfectly
because that's been an attack that's
taken by a lot of interpreters since
Descartes right you know
yeah I suppose um
first of all is there a difference uh
between the phrase perfect being and
phrase that in which nothing greater
could be could see yeah I would say yeah
what is a substantive yeah one is an
indefinite description based upon a
certain kind of relation
it's hard to think of what could
constitute being perfect unless you have
you know something
which is going to be perfect something
which is going to be perfected brought
to the highest level that it's so then
you've got some sort of capping right
uh that would be part of the problem of
the of the logic of perfection yeah is
it the case that any conception of
perfection requires a set of limits
that are going to Define what Perfection
means
uh and I think that that might be true
yeah sure
is there anything else you'd like to say
about the Institute or your role in it
or
been a what a long straight trip it's
been yeah yeah I remember meeting you at
the first St Anselm conference yeah 15
years ago so I had no idea that the the
back history that stretched back an
additional 10 years yeah it was sort of
an idea in the making quite some time
yeah
certainly glad that it came to fruition
people were beating down The Doors
well thanks very much